who do you want to be it's a simple
question and whether you know it or not
you're answering it every day through
your actions this one question will
define your professional success more
than any other because how you show up
in treat people means everything either
you lift people up by respecting them
making them feel valued appreciated and
heard or you hold people down by making
them feel small insulted disregarded or
excluded and who you choose to be means
everything I study the effects of
incivility on people
what is incivility it's disrespect or
rudeness it includes a lot of different
behaviors from mocking or belittling
someone to teasing people in ways that
sting to telling offensive jokes to
texting and meetings and what's uncivil
to one person may be absolutely fine to
another take texting while someone's
speaking to you some of us may find it
rude others may think it's absolutely
civil so it really depends it's all in
the eyes of the beholder
and whether that person felt
disrespected we may not mean to make
someone feel that way but when we do it
has consequences over 22 years ago I
vividly recall walking into the stuffy
hospital room it was heartbreaking to
see my dad the strong athletic energetic
guy lying in the bed with electrodes
strapped to his bare chest what put him
there
was work-related stress for over a
decade he suffered an uncivil boss and
for me I thought he was just an outlier
at that time but just a couple years
later I witnessed and experienced a lot
of incivility in my first job out of
college
I spent a year going to work everyday
and hearing things from co-workers like
are you an idiot that's not how it's
done and if I wanted your opinion I'd
ask so I did the natural thing I quit
and I went back to grad school to study
the effects of this and there I met
Christine Pearson and she had a theory
that small uncivil actions can lead to
much bigger problems like aggression and
violence
we believe that incivility affected
performance in the bottom line so we
launched a study and what we found was I
open a we sent a survey to Business
School alumni working in all different
organizations and we asked them to write
a few sentences about one experience
where they were treated rudely
disrespectfully earned sensitively and
to answer questions about how they
reacted one person told us about a boss
that made insulting statements like
that's kindergarteners work and another
tore up someone's work in front of the
entire team and what we found is that
incivility made people less motivated
66% cut back work efforts 80% lost time
worrying about what happened and 12%
left their jobs and after we published
these results two things happen one we
got calls from organizations Cisco read
about these numbers took just a few of
these and estimated conservatively
incivility was costing them 12 million
dollars a year the second thing that
happened was that we heard from others
in our academic field who said well
people are reporting this but how can
you really show it does peoples
performance really suffer I was curious
about that too with Amir Erez I compared
those that experienced incivility to
those that didn't experience incivility
and what we found is that those that
experienced incivility do actually
function much worse okay you may say
this may
since after all it's natural that their
performance suffers but what about if
you're not the one who experiences it
what if you just see or hear it you're a
witness we wondered if it affected
witnesses too so we conducted studies
where five participants would witness an
experiment or act rudely who someone who
arrived late to the study the
experimenter said what is it with you
you arrived late you're irresponsible
look at you how do you expect to hold a
job in the real world and in another
study in a small group we tested the
effects of a peer insulting a group
member now what we found was really
interesting because witnesses
performance decreased - and not just
marginally quite significantly
incivility is a bug it's contagious and
we become carriers of it just by being
around it and this isn't confined to the
workplace we can catch this virus
anywhere at home online in schools and
in our communities it affects our
emotions our motivation our performance
and how we treat others it even affects
our attention and could take some of our
brain power and this happens not only if
we experience incivility or we witness
it
it can happen even if we just see or
read rude words let me give you an
example of what I mean
to test this we gave people combinations
of words to use to make a sentence but
we were very sneaky half the
participants got a list with 15 words
used to trigger rudeness and politely
interrupt obnoxious bother half the
participants received a list of words
with none of these rude triggers and
what we found was really surprising
because the people who got the rude
words were 5 times more likely to miss
information right in front of them on
the computer screen and as we continued
this research what we found is
those that read the rude words took
longer to make decisions to record their
decisions and they made significantly
more errors this can be a big deal
especially when it comes to
life-and-death situations Steve a
physician told me about a doctor that he
worked with who was never very
respectful
especially to junior staff and nurses
but Steve told me about this one
particular interaction where this doctor
shouted at a medical team right after
the interaction the team gave the wrong
dosage of medication to their patient
Steve said the information was right
there on the chart but somehow everyone
on the team missed it he said they lack
the attention or awareness to take it
into account
simple mistake right will that patient
died researchers in Israel have actually
shown that medical teams exposed to
rudeness perform worse not only in all
their Diagnostics but in all the
procedures they did this was mainly
because the team's exposed to rudeness
didn't share information as readily and
they stopped seeking help from their
teammates and I see this not only in
medicine but in all industries so if
incivility has such a huge cost why do
we still see so much of it
I was curious so we surveyed people
about this - the number one reason is
stress people feel overwhelmed the other
reason that people are not more civil is
because they're skeptical and even
concerned about being civil or appearing
nice they believe they'll appear less
leader like they wonder do nice guys
finish last or in other words do jerks
get ahead it's easy to think so
especially when we see a few prominent
examples that dominate the conversation
well turns out in the long run they
don't there's really rich research on
this by Morgan McCall and Michael
Lombardo where they were at the center
for creative leadership
and they found the number one reason
tied to executive failure was an
insensitive abrasive or bullying style
there will always be some outliers that
succeed despite their incivility sooner
or later though most uncivil people
sabotage their success for example with
uncivil executives it comes back to hurt
them when they're in a place of weakness
or they need something people won't have
their backs but what about nice guys
does civility pay yes it does
and being civil doesn't just mean that
you're not a jerk
not holding someone down isn't the same
as lifting them up being truly civil
means doing the small things like
smiling and saying hello in the hallway
listening fully when someone's speaking
to you now you can have strong opinions
disagree have conflict or give negative
feedback civilly with respect some
people call it radical candor where you
care personally but you challenge
directly so yes
civility pays in a biotechnology firm
colleagues and I found that those that
were seen as civil were twice as likely
to be viewed as leaders and they
performed significantly better
why does civility pay because people see
you is an important in a powerful unique
combination of two key characteristics
warm and competent friendly and smart
another words being civil isn't just
about motivating others it's about youth
if you're civil you're more likely to be
seen as a leader you'll perform better
and you're seen as warm and competent
but there's an even bigger story about
how civility pays and it ties to one of
the most important questions around
leadership what do people want most from
their leaders we took data from over
20,000 employees around the world and we
found the answer was simple respect
being treated with respect
was more important than recognition and
appreciation useful feedback even
opportunities for learning those that
felt respected were healthier more
focused more likely to stay with their
organization and far more engaged so
where do you start
how can you lift people up and make
people feel respected well the nice
thing is it doesn't require a huge shift
small things can make a big difference
I found that thanking people sharing
credit listening attentively humbly
asking questions acknowledging others
and smiling has an impact
Patrick Quinlan former CEO of Aashna
Healthcare told me about the effects of
their 10:5 way where if you're within 10
feet of someone you make eye contact and
smile and if you're within 5 feet you
say hello
he explained that civility spread
patient satisfaction scores rose as did
patient referrals civility and respect
can be used to boost an organization's
performance when my friend Doug Conant
took over a CEO of Campbell Soup Company
in 2001 the company's market share had
just dropped in half sales were
declining lots of people had just been
laid off a Gallup manager said it was
the least engaged organization that they
had surveyed and as Doug drove up to
work his first day he noticed that the
headquarters was surrounded by barbed
wire fence there were guard towers in
the parking lot he said it looked like a
minimum security prison
it felt toxic within five years Doug had
turned things around and within nine
years they were setting all-time
performance records and racking up
awards including best place to work how
did he do it on day one Doug told
employees that he was going to have high
standards for performance but they were
gonna do it with civility he walked the
talk
and he expected his leaders to for Doug
it all came down to being tough minded
Oxley it hurts and tender-hearted with
people and for him he said it was all
about these touch points or these daily
interactions he had with employees
whether in the hallway in the cafeteria
or in meetings and if he handled each
touch point well he'd make employees
feel valued another way that Doug made
employees feel valued and showed them
that he was paying attention is that he
hand wrote over 30,000 thank-you notes
two employees and this set an example
for other leaders leaders have about 400
of these touch points a day most don't
take long less than two minutes each the
key is to be agile and mindful in each
of these moments civility lifts people
will get people to give more and
function at their best if we're civil
incivility chips away at people and
their performance it robs people of
their potential even if they're just
working around it what I know from my
research is that when we have more civil
environments were more productive
creative helpful happy and healthy we
can do better each one of us can be more
mindful and can take actions to lift
others up around us at work at home
online in schools and in our communities
in every interaction think who do you
want to be let's put an end to the
incivility bug and start spreading
civility after all it pays thank you
[Applause]